ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
annual president's Town Hall my name is
Steve clean work in marketing and
communications and without further ado
I'd like to introduce dr. subra Suresh
thank you so I guess it's already
afternoon so good afternoon thank you
Steve for all the Cubs fans out there as
long as Cleveland is beat and I think
people in Pittsburgh cheer for this so
I'm reminded I have to start with my
favorite philosophers coat yogi Berra's
coat Yogi Berra the baseball player
Legend and the famous American
philosopher once said about winning
congratulations i knew the record would
stand until it was broken so
congratulations to all the Cubs fans so
I'm really thrilled to welcome you to
the annual Carnegie Mellon town hall for
those who are still standing there are
more seats here please come and sit here
since coming to Carnegie Mellon I pledge
that we will maintain an open dialogue
with students faculty staff and alumni
through a variety of forums so even as
we initiated a number of arranged
opportunities informal opportunities for
this conversation through various events
and forums in addition to events that
Mary and I hold at the residents
throughout the year this town hall is a
great opportunity for all of us to come
together to share ideas to give you an
opportunity to ask questions to me
share your thoughts and equally provide
insights and input that we can follow
through during the year of course the
time is not enough to capture all of
this input that's why we have so many
other opportunities in true CMU fashion
this year technology will play a major
role allowing even more people to
participate students faculty staff and
alumni and parents are encouraged to
view our webcast or participate in the
Q&A on facebook life and via the mobile
app slider will see it on the screen
which you can find here in fact about 15
minutes ago I was thrilled to see that
there were already many people who are
online and some had submitted questions
as well so before I open the floor for
questions and discussion I want to
quickly update you on a few things just
take a few minutes to give some opening
remarks first of all I'd want to
recognize people who are contributing
throughout the year and for a long
period of time to this great University
in so many different ways visible and
invisible ways first of all all of you
who took the time from your busy
schedules to come here my wife Mary
who's here members of the senior
leadership team and the deans vice
provost vice presidents represent
representatives from the Faculty Senate
and the student government and students
faculty staff and alumni from our
campuses around the world there are
three items that I want to quickly touch
upon all of them emanate from our
strategic plan 2025 which many of you so
enthusiastically participated in and we
rolled it out just about a year ago and
many of you continue to engage in the
implementation of that strategic plan
first and foremost our desire to attract
and retain out outstanding and diverse
talent among faculty students and staff
in this effort you received my email
earlier this week announcing the boards
the Board of Trustees endorsement to put
in a significant fraction of the patent
litigation settlement into the permanent
endowment of the university to benefit
long-term how we engage our students
give access to our students support our
faculty and staff so let me thank all of
you for your for your efforts in
contributing to this many people have
contributed to this over many years I
won't individually thank them here but
you've had a series of communications to
that effort through eight months of work
we had an ad hoc committee that engaged
a number of colleagues to 77
recommendations from across CMU and
found a remarkable consensus that the
resources should benefit our University
in a lasting way based on that consensus
the Board of Trustees endorsed investing
more than eighty percent of the proceeds
into the endowment and earmarking them
specifically I can use the word year
mark here when I was in the government I
was told not to use that for obvious
reasons undergraduate scholarships and
graduate fellowships faculty chairs
supporting ambitious research projects
that make a real-world impact supporting
professional development of staff and
faculty what's left will be devoted to
and what's left is not a trivial sum of
money that will be devoted to immediate
needs in support of enhancing the CMU
experience another new resource that
will significantly enhance the CMU
experience by capitalizing on our unique
strengths was what was announced
yesterday morning through a new 10
million dollar gift from the
K&L Gates Foundation will establish an
undergraduate scholarship new faculty
chairs presidential fellowships for
doctoral students presidential
scholarship for an undergraduate an
undergraduate student price and a
biennial conference that will focus on
something that CMU is very good at CMU
many decades ago pioneered the field of
artificial intelligence but as more and
more of that is adopted by humanity on a
global scale we also face questions of
ethics how technology impacts the human
behavior and that's an area where
through work not just in engineering and
computer science but equally in Dietrich
college Hines College of Public Policy
and management and EPP and Business
School and many other entities all
across campus we address these questions
at the intersection of society humanity
and technology these enhancements and
others we have are already undertaken
are already having an immediate effect
on Carnegie Mellon most notably in our
ability to recruit and retain a diverse
student body faculty and staff unless
you've been hunkered down well inside
the hunt library are locked up in a
research lab are holed up in a rehearsal
studio or in your office you will have
heard that for the first time in
Carnegie Mellon history nearly half 49.8
percent of this year's first year class
or women students
add to that there are some amazing
statistics things that have bothered
many people at the national level there
are some things at carnegie mellon is
doing extremely well there are amazing
news about women in our class of 2020
while they make up about sixteen percent
of the first year computer science class
in universities across the country at
CMU women first-year students make up
forty-eight percent three times the
national average thanks in large measure
to a lot of very hard work by faculty
and a leadership in in the School of
Computer Science and across campus in
the admissions office and so forth my
congratulations to them and women make
up about twenty percent of the
first-year engineering class in
universities across the u.s. at Carnegie
Mellon this fall forty-three percent of
the first year engineering class or
women students more than twice the
national average my congratulations to
colleagues in engineering with the
announcement of the recent endowment
earlier this week endowment added to
support students from the pattern
settlement we also have this fall the
second cohort of presidential fellows
and scholars currently there are 255
students who who received the ADA the
presidential fellowship or a
presidential scholarship with the recent
additions and recent gifts that we have
received the endowment the permanent
endowment that is that has been set
aside just for presidential scholarships
and fellowships has now grown in excess
of 285 million dollars just in a little
over two years so my thanks and
congratulations to all of you
and forty-nine percent of presidential
scholars and fellows or women students
so we have a little room to grow to to
reach parity there my second update
concerns another strategic plan
objective which is enhancing the CMU
experience just five days ago we
convened the first meeting of the
president's advisory board for the CMU
experience this external group of health
wellness and higher education
professionals are offering as their
expertise on improving the academic and
professional life of all CMU students
faculty and staff they we put them to
very hard work starting with the weekend
and will be receiving their formal input
very shortly and will be taking actions
on those inputs you also heard that we
took a step last semester adding
round-the-clock access to universities
counseling and psychological services
services known as cap so that students
who need to see a counselor will have
their access to do so round-the-clock we
have significantly increased the effort
to do this these this external advisory
board and other measures that have been
taken will complement the very important
work already underway by the internal
task force for the CMU experience that
includes the leadership of the
university it includes faculty staff and
students members of the faculty senate
and student government and many of you
are already taken note of our new first
first day of class emphasis on informing
students about campus support services
and this is just one of many many steps
that we will take tactical and strategic
that will help improve the CMU
experience just a couple of weeks ago I
was extremely pleased to see so many of
you join us for an informal gathering at
fence to reflect on important issues
facing our society CMU faculty and staff
for here to do all we can to facilitate
these important dialogues and various
student leaders are helping make us
aware of opportunities for university
leadership and for faculty to converse
with student groups about events big and
small and issues big and small that
affect all of our lives especially in
this very troublesome election year
enhancing the CMU experience also
includes other efforts it includes our
commitment to make increases and
improvements in the availability of
child care for faculty staff and
graduate students as expanded
opportunities will come into existence
just in a few months from now we are
also committed to creating a new health
and wellness center by approximately
early 2019 which will be nearly double
the size of the current health and
wellness center this year we are also
piloting a new CMU host family program
for international students such efforts
complement the good work that Carnegie
Mellon already does as we speak one of
our most helpful community service
projects the CMU food drive is underway
across our campus last year's effort
achieved record results raising nine
thousand dollars and more than 7,000
pounds of non-perishable items donated
to the Greater Pittsburgh Community Food
Bank with your help we can eclipse that
this year so give all that you can and
please continue to participate in the
many community service opportunities
this university offers the final item I
wish to note is our recent hosting of
President Barack Obama for the White
House frontiers conference even if you
are locked away in the library or
anywhere else
it would have been hard for you to miss
this President Obama very deliberately
chose Carnegie Mellon University and pit
and the city of Pittsburgh for the final
major conference of his presidency
because of our comprehensive excellence
and track record of technological
innovation his third visit to Carnegie
Mellon during his tenure at the White
House drew hundreds of science
technology and policy thought leaders as
well as top local state and federal
officials which significantly amplified
CMU's prestige around the country and
around the world so the events such as
the Washington Post news item about
women in computer science and
engineering uber affiliating with
Carnegie Mellon and introducing their
first driverless uber in the city of
Pittsburgh the president's frontier
conference have all brought global
attention to Carnegie Mellon University
in fact Steve claim informed me recently
that the president's visit alone had
more than 1 billion media impressions
that mention Carnegie Mellon University
I think it's a record for for any visit
for it by anybody so the president came
to Carnegie Mellon because of your work
work that matters so before I open the
floor for questions and comments I want
to take this opportunity to applaud all
of you especially and the various groups
that are represented here the
outstanding students faculty staff and
alumni some of you are also alumni here
who make Carnegie Mellon such an amazing
University I'll be very happy to take
any questions you may have
thanks so much subra as president
mentioned we're taking questions in four
different ways to try to get as many
voices in as we can we had several dozen
questions submitted online in advance we
will take at least a couple of questions
live here in the room and we have Kate
and Jen with microphones so raise your
hand if you find a break and see if you
can get their attention and we'll try to
get to you we also want to first of all
welcome our Facebook live stream viewers
you have your own way to ask questions
which is in the comment field and
finally something new we're trying this
year is super mentioned slide oh you can
go to this from your phone here in the
room you can go if you're watching the
live stream from your office but you can
also join us because we have free
refreshments here and it's easy to sign
on use the town word town hall as your
code to get in you click join event one
thing it doesn't say there it will ask
you a poll question when you sign on we
just wanted to get a sense of the
affiliation of people who are tuned in
so it'll ask you if your faculty staff
or student them so please help us with
that and obviously this is going to be
far more questions and we can answer in
an hour but we'll try to get a
representation of different voices and
different topics and and then we will
make sure that all of those questions
are shared across the senior leadership
team so even if your question doesn't
make it on to the live doesn't make it
on the air today know that you're being
heard and that we're talking about these
things so thanks again for your
participation first question was
submitted in advance by a staff member
Felicia Evans who asks for a little more
detail on what is being done to add
diversity here at CMU so one of the
items that came through loud and clear
in our strategic plan is a strong
reinforcement of one of the fundamental
values of the university that we are a
place where diversity of thought racial
diversity gender diversity and diversity
of perspectives and ideas and opinions
and lifestyles or should be cherished
cherish
so from a university's perspective in
terms of looking at our strategic plan
for the next 10 years or so there are
many different things that come to mind
first and foremost starting with me
diversity has to be a continuous pursuit
for the leadership of the University it
also has to be a continuous pursuit for
all of us it's not just one person in
one office who recognizes the importance
of this in our daily actions in the ways
in which we treat one another the
respect we show for one another that
respect we show for different viewpoints
while cherishing our freedom of
expression for which Carnegie Mellon was
recognized as one of the top
universities that values freedom of
expression region recently in a national
ranking and so with all of this I think
there are specific steps that we can
take starting with a administrative
offices for example continuing to
reinforce the importance of diversity
among our staff in the academic units as
we look for excellence around the
country how do we make sure that we
attract the best and the brightest that
represent different perspectives
different life experiences and different
viewpoints we need resources in some
areas for some segments there is stiff
competition on a global scale for a
limited pool of talent we need resources
for this this is why we need
presidential fellowships and
scholarships startup packages for
faculty endowed chairs for junior
faculty and senior faculty and and the
tone that we said so we recently started
last year through one of the vice
provost Katherine roeder looking at
sensitivity training for faculty and
staff and I think this kind of activity
can spread across across the campus so
there are it's not just one set of
actions it's not at one point in time
this is a continuous set of principles
by which we live that we hold ourselves
accountable at all layers of the
organization
where we cherish the fundamental values
of having a diverse and inclusive
community where members of that
community respect one another on a
day-to-day basis and I think this is and
there are specific metrics this is not
an easy issue this is not an issue we
can address in one or two years in a
complex organization like Carnegie
Mellon University but over a five to ten
year for ison by all of us engaging in
this we can really move the needle and
we can also put resources behind it it's
not just empty talk and slogans and this
is why we want to make sure that we have
adequate resources in our endowment to
support these kinds of activities thank
you want to make sure we leave time if
there's a question live here in the hall
any hands raised I'm going to go to
slide out where we have a number of
questions thank you one that seems to be
getting attention more than some of the
others and that's one of the fun things
about salida we can tell who's given it
a thumbs up is a question regarding
gender parity at the graduate level and
Daniel Gingrich notes that we aren't
doing as well at the graduate level as
the the numbers we've been able to show
this year with incoming undergraduates
what can we do in that realm I think you
know it varies across the undergraduate
student population I meant I gave two
examples of computer science and
engineering there are only limited
examples but if you look at the graduate
student population there is significant
heterogeneity in the numbers of with
respect to gender parity if you look at
some areas that I'm familiar with if you
look at areas such as biology material
science and engineering and chemical
engineering typically in many of the
leading research universities you have
more women graduate students than men
graduate students but there are other
areas there are very few women graduate
students I don't know what the numbers
are today but a few years ago areas such
as computer science and mechanical
engineering in most universities at
national average the number of women was
relative relatively small so there is a
significant disparity among disciplines
so we need to keep that in mind and it
varies drama
matically even within within a college
across departments having said that I
think just as in the case of the School
of Computer Science where the national
average is not looking good Carnegie
Mellon faculty and staff and leadership
took a proactive role in trying to fix
the problem and show take a--take a
national leadership role this is
something I think we can try to do
across disciplines across many
disciplines and I think it's needs to be
done on a case-by-case basis one of the
ways in which we can address this in a
very tangible way would be making more
resources available for some of some of
you who are new to the University two
years ago when we looked at the numbers
there are approximately 2,000 PhD
students on campus our ability about a
million dollars in endowment supports
the tuition of one graduate student for
one year but in perpetuity we had about
67 million dollars in endowment which
will support 67 tuitions for 67 PhD
students out of a population of 2,000
students and we are now about 150
million dollars or so with respect to
our fellowship that number needs to go
to about a billion dollars then we will
really see a big difference and we can
effectively compete so these are some of
the mechanisms supporting young faculty
and senior faculty with the flexibility
to hire graduate students who are highly
qualified as another area on another
topic thank you another question
submitted in advance is by a group of
faculty members and I know this has been
a topic of interest throughout the fall
is about the wages for employees of CMU
vendors these are the people who work in
food service in a variety of other parts
of the university who aren't employed
technically by the university but
they're part of our daily lives and as
one question or pointed out off in a
first point of contact for students and
others what can we do to ensure that
that these employees are paid a living
wage so we have a
a number of employees of the university
but the university like all
organizations also employs vendors who
are not those employees of the vendors
are not employees of Carnegie Mellon
University but having said that many of
these people have worked for the
university for a very very long period
of time and one of the things I think we
need to do especially at a time when
there is a significant national
conversation about disparity in income
income inequality and also stagnating
wages especially people who have to work
two or three jobs one of the things we
can do as a university is to engage with
our vendors in such a way that their
employees their practices as they engage
with Carnegie Mellon are consistent with
our values if their values are not
consistent with our values I think we
need to think through a process and
again this is not instantaneous this is
not immediate there are serious
financial ramifications in a limited
budget on how we balance this so this is
an important issue and I want to share
with you something that really touched
me about a couple of months ago Mary and
I hosted a breakfast reception at the
residence for above at 6am for the night
time employees of Carnegie Mellon
University these are many of the
custodial staff and they were also staff
who have worked at the president's
residence but we have never been inside
the residence so we invited about 150 of
them to come for breakfast and we also
hosted an event at the end of the day
for the daytime employees one thing that
really moved me in this so they worked
from 11pm to 7am they left their shift
ends at 7am and specifically for this
breakfast we stopped their shift at 6am
and had them come over to the residence
and I realized and this is a national
trend I realized that I we had wonderful
food for them and we asked some of them
to stay as long as they wanted
because there was a lot of food left and
they said no we have to go because we
have another job to go to and one of the
employees one of the vendors employees
actually told me he didn't have the
opportunity to go to university he's
determined to put his son to get a
chemical engineering degree at one of
the universe just you know these are the
kinds of things that bring you to tears
and so these are members of our
community how do we address this given
all the constraints and resource
constraints that we have and how do we
engage with the vendors so that so that
we can over over some reasonable period
of time make sure our values are
consistent with this so that would be my
respiration thank you very much here's
question that came over slide Oh about
an element of the lawsuit settlement
proceeds that that you didn't address in
your remarks and that is specifically
how they might benefit the College of
Engineering Cathy bugatchi the
questioner here is asking specifically
about infrastructure will anything go
toward engineering buildings and
equipment but I imagine there others who
want to know more broadly how this works
so I can address that in two three
different ways of course the invention
that led to the litigation settlement
came out of the College of Engineering
so this is one of the reasons why it was
important that the ad hoc committee that
was shared by the Provost also included
the Dean of engineering so that he can
represent his faculty and staff and
students in the process itself and this
group went with a large group of cohorts
so based on recommendations from a wide
cross-section of the community based on
conversations with faculty students
staff and alumni and inventors and the
trustees this committee the ad hoc
committee came to a unanimous consensus
and recommendation that about one-third
of the settlement go to benefit the
College of Engineering
and in terms of scholarships fellowships
the other unanimous recommendation was
also that a significant fraction of the
resources that we set aside not just for
engineering but for the whole university
goat for the long-term benefit that
means endowment not immediate expendable
so this will benefit the College of
Engineering over a long period of time
and there are units within engineering
for example the electrical and computer
engineering department dssc the digital
data storage system center DSS see where
the invention took place so this is
within the College of Engineering for
these faculty and staff to work together
there was a question about buildings so
this is one of the interesting things to
think about Carnegie Mellon's endowment
the university was founded in nineteen
hundred in 2012 which is just four years
ago our endowment reached a 1 billion
mark okay to 112 years our goal is to
bring the endowment from 1 billion to 2
billion in the next couple of years so
for a university of this size and this
history we cannot afford to have an
endowment as small as this we cannot
rely on the federal government for
continued support we cannot rely on
Annual Giving alone especially if the
economy tanks so to the question about
buildings we've been very fortunate to
be right in the middle of perhaps the
largest infrastructure expansion of the
University in a five year period since
its inception and we're doing the vast
majority of it through fundraising so
when the tapper quad project the largest
building to come into existence will be
completed we hope to do that without the
need to borrow any funds at all for a
200 million dollar building so we need
to balance those activities that require
fundraising versus those activities for
example supporting students through
scholarship
and fellowships supporting faculty
through endowment endowments and chairs
etc we need to have a good balance
between endowment and expendable and
because our balance had not been well
balanced if you will we had to address
that issue and that's why there was a
unanimous recommendation to put a
significant resources from the
settlement into our endowment to benefit
the students and faculty and staff for
the long haul wonderful things questions
in the room oh it's there's a live
question some years ago we had a speaker
come to our University and give a talk
in the evening in which he explained
that he had done anonymous surveys of
college student teaching and found very
large fractions of the students at some
institutions he named who admitted
anonymously to cheating he did not give
any numbers for Carnegie Mellon I think
he didn't want to be undiplomatic but if
I sort of inferred from what he'd said
that we probably to have a serious
problem do you have any thoughts on this
yes so let me first and say we have
phenomenal cohort of students at
Carnegie Mellon University equally we
have a very rigorous process of
addressing departures from ideal
behavior and I it's each case is
different and I think it's very
important that we look at the bigger
picture specific cases look at the
details underlying it and I think this
is why in the in the few years that I've
been here on this campus and in general
being in academia for more than 35 years
looking dealing with thousands and
thousands of students I've come to
understand that we cannot generalize for
all students and we have to take it on a
case-by-case basis if you look at large
numbers our student population
it is truly wonderful having had having
had academic tenure in more than two
institutions actually three institutions
three very different institutions I
would say we are so fortunate to have
the kind of faculty and students we have
at Carnegie Mellon University thank you
very much let me take a question
submitted in advance by one of our alums
Jessie her an how to CMU plan to improve
its US News and World Report rankings
and generate more media coverage great
rankings are very important but if
rankings is our goal we are not doing a
good job I think ranking is is an end to
a journey not the goal post that we try
to seek I think there are several things
we can do the priorities of the three
priorities there are the overarching
priorities of Carnegie Mellon University
that you have articulated in our
strategic plan which encompassed 24
different action items which are on the
website those three are attracting and
retaining top and diverse talent
enriching the CMU experience and
enabling uniformity of excellence across
campus if we succeed in all three
rankings will follow in addition to that
if we can get presidents of the
university 1 billion impressions on
global media get the CMU name out around
the world and not be a stealth
institution that will increase the
rankings the students are very
passionate we have a new advancement
group which is very passionate about led
by Scott Murray who joined us about a
year ago and this group and as well as
student leaders are very passionate
about advancement and cultivating a
culture of giving to the University and
if we succeed in this in the next 10
years much more so than our history as
indicated then that will add to our
ranking so there are so many different
things new facilities new buildings new
labs new makers
new nano fabrication facilities brain
have science at CMU there are many many
things that can improve the overall
quality and attract top talent so I
think it's while rankings are important
we need to pay attention rankings are
not the ones we pursue for the sake of
ranking some universities try to do this
but I think Carnegie Mellon has a level
of distinction and academic
sophistication that it seeks quality and
excellence rather than rankings and I
think ranking should be a byproduct of
that pursuit of excellence and quality
thank you our slide Oh audience seems to
be coalescing behind this question
related to the CMU experience does CMU
have any concrete plans to change
curriculum and deal with stress related
issues among students so changing the
curriculum as a university president I
would not want to get into the middle of
that should be done by the faculty and
faculty should be in charge of changing
the curriculum but having said that it's
very important I have to point out that
the task force the internal task force
led by our Provost is very much looking
at academic matters in fact so many
faculty are very passionate about what
causes stress I mean we don't want to
lose academic rigor but just having
academic rigor doesn't mean it has to be
stressful so how do we balance the
excellence for which Carnegie Mellon is
known for with a culture where in
reality and perception students and
faculty and staff don't feel stressed
out I think this is important do you
need 15 hours of homework to be
excellent can you do that with 12 hours
of homework per subject for three
subjects or four subjects this is up to
the faculty to decide I think this is
very much part and parcel of the
conversation that the internal task
force is looking at I think
input from students and faculty will be
very critical to this we can do some
other things this is why the health and
wellness center in terms of counseling
time management both for for all of us
especially me and and many others how do
we how do we manage our time most
effectively so rather than trying
quantifying success on the basis of how
many things you do maybe peak
performance is a metric whatever you do
your peak performance is what makes you
successful in your own definition in
your own mind so I think how do we get
how do we provide the support
infrastructure that will make it
conducive for people to achieve their
best potential without being stressed
out I think that that's part of the goal
including an academic side absolutely
any questions here in the room we've got
a couple up front here hold on just a
moment we'll get you a microphone so we
can all hear it
I was so now I think that could it be a
great mistake at the time we were coming
into the technology there are only four
or five Institute's it had that kind of
title in the country I would suggest you
consider the possibility of waking it up
tomorrow I'm telling us we have a
graduate school so I the perspective you
have is not something that I have
because I was not on earth when you came
to Carnegie Tech so I I appreciate that
perspective that I lack so let me let me
say a couple of things I think the
president of the University at that time
the name of the University changed from
Carnegie Tech or Carnegie University to
carnegie mellon university was guy
stever and when he finished the job it
was such a massive effort he left
carnegie mellon university to become
director of the National Science
Foundation I just want to remind you I
came the other way so so just a couple
of I think change of name is not a
trivial consideration our undergraduate
population by every metric the freshman
who entered Carnegie Mellon this
semester is the best class ever and
every year it's getting better and
better
and so we have 6000 wonderful
undergraduate students we have 2,000
outstanding PhD students and the rest
are master students at Carnegie Mellon
and I think any change of flavor has to
come from the entire community and we
have so many wonderful things and
underway in terms of priorities and
availability of time change of the
designation of the university or its
intellectual flavor probably will not be
on I won't have the bandwidth to take on
given all the other important things
that are there but I think looking at
the enormous strength of the university
and how to capture that strength oh look
all across the campus and elevate the
university is something that that's very
much in the discussion of our strategic
plan and its implementation over the
next several years I'm going to take a
question from our Facebook audience
which is one we've encountered before it
at gatherings like this but I think it's
important because it's it's top of mind
for so many of our students and families
and that is what is CM you doing to
address rising tuition costs so a number
of things it's no secret that our
tuition is among the highest in the
country and even though our living
expenses for students are not close to
the highest they are still high so the
total package is quite high and an our
dependence on tuition for operating
expenses is much more than the
institutions with whom we compete so put
it another way the institutions with
with which we compete for students and
faculty at Carnegie Mellon have
endowments which are nearly an order of
magnitude greater than what we have the
Institute's that I have n down went
comparable to our hours are not our
competitors at all not our intellectual
competitors so that's the unusual
position we are in so what exactly can
we do first and foremost our commitment
to attracting students going back to
endowed scholarships and fellowships
more and more students getting them that
will not only help attract top women
students will help attract top
under-represented groups to come to
Carnegie Mellon in a stiff competition
where we are going after every
university is going going after limited
pool of talent same with faculty so
that's one part of it there is another
part of it we worked very hard for the
incoming class this semester so that
students who have demonstrated need who
are brilliant who get admitted to
Carnegie Mellon but cannot afford a
Carnegie Mellon education we made sure
that we can find a pathway for them to
come to Carnegie Mellon University we
have not publicized this but the reason
we cannot we are not in a position to
make it a policy is we don't have the
resources to make it possible for all
such student you have to start somewhere
you have to start in steps and as we go
through as we look at next few years
this is why endowment is so critical so
that we can give more scholarships
increase our discount rate make it
affordable for students to come and you
will see that you've seen that in the
last 23 years by a steady drumbeat of
message that we have given we are able
to attract the kind of student
persistence is another issue through
leadership from our campus affairs group
lisa creek mike murphy and others we
worked very hard to make sure the
persistence numbers increase supporting
students pell grant students making sure
this this semester we have a little more
than ten percent of our incoming
freshman class or students who are first
in their family to go to college we want
to make sure that that number increases
diversity western Pennsylvania is the
law the fastest growing demographic
group in the country is the Hispanic
population and western Pennsylvania
doesn't have very much of that so if you
want to represent the National
demographics we have strategic
disadvantages because of her geography
how do we address this how do we attract
students who are brilliant but who will
not come all the way to pittsburgh
getting the word out of the carnegie
mellon to the high schools so the top
students can come here the largest state
the state from which the largest number
of students come to Carnegie Mellon this
semester is not Pennsylvania it's
California and it's all because of our
weather and Google came why can't they
come so so I think so there is a lot of
these things but I think resources are a
very important part of it this is why
fundraising focus on end down and focus
on scholarships and fellowships and
professorships is so critical we have
time for just a couple more questions so
last call from the room there's one way
in back there if we're able to get a
microphone there hi I'm a first year
masters student in mechanical
engineering is my first semester and the
only issue i have is i have only two
more semesters to go wish i could have
had more but on a serious note you can
always do a PhD you know on a serious
note i have only a spring semester and
most of the courses that i'm interested
in comes in spring so if there could be
any flexibility in extending a graduate
program so that we could accommodate for
an extra spring or an extra fall that
could help students that we created well
thank you for your question I I don't
know the specifics of course offerings
in mechanical engineering even though
all my degrees are in mechanical
engineering I i wish i had the
opportunity to take classes at carnegie
mellon someday I might but I think it's
a question of resources the number of
topics that need to be covered our
mechanical engineering department in
terms of faculty is relatively small
compared to mechanical engineering
departments around the country with whom
we compete with a few faculty we do
extremely well with a relatively fewer
faculty compared to our peer
institutions we do extremely well so I
think it's a question of supply and
demand Alan Robinson is your department
head the next time I see him I will
bring this up with the Provost is here
listening to you and I don't I cannot
promise anything because I don't know
the what what perspectives they have but
this is something you should bring it up
with with your department thank you you
know this us as we know so Steve is from
Chicago as we know November third 2016
is going to be one of the great days in
sports history so I think it's only
fitting that we take one last question
related to sports and happily we were
obliged by not one but three different
badminton questions so a badminton
question they all revolve around that
there's a serious note to this to a
number of students who love bad men
they're passionate about badminton but
they're having trouble finding the time
in limited spaces on campus competing
with others you know something about
badminton don't you so first of all I
want to applaud the students for
thinking about physical fitness which I
wish I had time to think about more and
mary keeps reminding me I should be
thinking about that more and more as
well so that's the first thing the
second thing I want to share is when I
was a young assistant professor at Brown
University I used to play badminton with
some of my graduate students who are
roughly within a year or two of my age
at that time and we used to go play
every time I got beaten so badly it
tarnished me forever and I haven't
played badminton in quite some time so I
applaud you for doing this maybe one of
these days I'll pick up my racket which
I still have and come and play a game
with you to see how rusted i am with
respect to badminton but but more
seriously I think I was just thinking
about this quickly you you caught me
there because of all the issues I had to
think about this morning I apologize i
have not thought about badminton and i
haven't thought about it in quite some
time but seriously I
we are making it won't be an immediate
effect but we are making a concerted
effort and i will give you examples a
concerted effort in improving facilities
that we have not necessarily for
badminton but for for physical and
athletic facility physical fitness and
athletic facilities in general for
example last two to three years we spend
significant resources in creating the
fitness facility in this cowan
university center year and a half from
now we'll have a new fitness center come
into existence in the first building in
tepper quad and we are very fortunate to
have under the leadership of josh sent
or a wonderful cohort of student
athletes at carnegie mellon in fact in
Division three athletics I don't think
any other university can claim as many
nationally ranked athletes who are also
four-point-oh scholars as carnegie
mellon can and given that we have such
wonderful students it is important for
us to make sure that they have decent
facilities so even though renovation of
this keepo gym is not immediately on our
plan there are lots of conversations
taking place about how we can think
about as a next priority because i'm
told that it's one of the oldest
athletic facilities in a university so
this is something that we've had we've
been talking about for quite some time
so your point about badminton is well
taken but before we have a new badminton
court we may have a basketball court we
may have a tennis court we don't know
but fitness is very much on the radar
screen and there are concrete steps that
are being taken right now one at a time
given our resource constraints so thank
you for your question I think we can
wrap it up then if so I I don't have
anything more to add but I I think we we
will have events like this periodically
and I think all member all my colleagues
of this leadership team all the deans we
very much appreciate your taking the
time from your busy schedules to join us
this is not the only forum and there
not enough time to talk about all the
questions but we really welcome your
input even if we don't answer them I can
promise you that these questions will be
discussed in our senior leadership team
and appropriate divisions of the
University will take them up for
follow-up action I would also encourage
you to reach out to leaders of your
representative groups if you are a
student to your student body president
in fact vasavi came to see me yesterday
and this is another wonderful thing
about Carnegie Mellon University
compared to many other universities that
I have been fortunate enough to be part
of she not only came to see me to talk
about some issues she actually brought
me some food yesterday and I very much
appreciated it actually type of food
that I grew up with as a child so so I
want to encourage you to reach out to
leadership of your group well if you're
a staff member to the staff council if
you're a faculty member to the
department head Dean or provost and but
please don't hesitate to contact as your
input is very critical so please help us
do a better job so we very much welcome
you to join in this conversation not
just today not just once a year but
continuously thank you so much
just want to add my thanks to all of you
for taking your lunch hours to spend
time with us online or here in the room
talking about adding thanks even putting
together I didn't realize it until I
came to this particular job in different
jobs I recognized it to different extend
the people sitting over there and people
who are sitting in various places here
they've spent so much time even
organizing something like this
monitoring Facebook input slide o on
other things so let's give them a round
of our process thank you and please join
me one more time in thinking president
session